the television commercial as you and i
sit and have this discussion right now
is fundamentally over
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk i
hope everybody's doing super well i
haven't done
a interview on the podcast in quite a
long time
and i'm extremely excited to be doing so
here today
today we have a gentleman on the show
who is a marketer i admire
quite a bit from afar and recently we've
gotten to know each other and the timing
was perfect because
he's got a new book out and honestly
i've i've been talking a lot about
entrepreneurship
i've been talking a lot about um culture
and i felt like i just really wanted to
get into a little bit of depths of
marketing on the podcast and i couldn't
think of a better person
than raja and the timing of his
incredible new book so raja
visually because i know a lot of people
are listening but people will also watch
this
uh visually why don't you hold up your
book cover i've had the feeling of
having a book so i know it's like
having a child so it's fun to show off
with absolute pleasure
[Laughter]
here is my book and i feel so good about
it
very good russia why don't you tell
everybody who you are your name uh what
you do
and the book you just wrote and why you
wrote the book and then we'll get into
it
terrific so my name is raja rajamanar
and i'm the chief marketing and
communications officer for mastercard
i'm also the president of mastercard's
healthcare business
and i've been in the field of marketing
for more than 35 years
now and i have seen a lot of changes
over this period of time
and having served both on the business
management side
in addition to being on the functional
management of marketing
i have been able to get perspectives
from different angles
and as i see right now we are at the
verge
of an unprecedented level of disruption
as far as marketing goes predominantly
led by technologies that are coming at
us like a tsunami new technology is
coming at us like a tsunami
the current ways of doing marketing the
current strategies and the current
frameworks of marketing
will completely collapse immediately we
need to reinvent and
rethink marketing and my whole book
called quantum marketing
exactly does that it says what these new
technologies are
what the new data capabilities are what
the cultural shifts are
and how is it going to impact marketing
in ways that were absolutely we could
not imagine
and therefore what the solution should
be how do you look at every aspect of
marketing
like whether it is loyalty or
advertising or consumer insights be it
whichever part of the ecosystem
are the processes of marketing how do
you reinvent it so i'm challenging a lot
of our existing uh you know
theories and concepts around marketing
and i'm saying they are
totally useless at this point in time as
we are just entering the fifth paradigm
that's what i call the new phase of
marketing where all these disruptions
are happening and how marketers can be
successful
so this book carries a little bit like a
playbook at a very high level
uh for the marketing folks uh across all
the levels right from the cmo
uh down to somebody who's just beginning
their career in marketing
it's because i kept i simplified it so
much and
demystified the whole thing uh that
people will really have fun reading it
and
it could be inspiring as much as it is
daunting
raja uh on the daunting part obviously
you know i'm listening to you and i'm
like oh this is good
uh because you know as you know i'm a
human and a company in the marketing
ecosystem that is
speaking to hey the way we've been doing
this is very very vulnerable
so i'm curious in detail
what is one of the biggest
vulnerabilities
i mean you know you just made such an
important
powerful statement that that hey the way
we've been marketing
is about to get massively disrupted and
honestly i think we probably both agree
with this
that's why you probably wrote it down
it's already been disrupted yet
the actions are lagging behind in your
opinion
maybe one or two scenarios where that
has happened where where do you think
the conventional marketing industry
is bullish on something and you're like
no no no my friends
in the framework of quantum like this is
a problem and we need to have this
honest discussion yeah so again
in fact you're absolutely right that
already the disruptions have happened
but my assertion is that the disruption
we have seen
is nothing if you look at any shift in
the past
it was predominantly a couple of
technologies like when we moved from
paradigm one to paradigm two it was just
radio and television in a big way
two to three was data analytics and
internet
three to four is social media and mobile
devices
now two-two technologies in each stage
but now we are getting more than two
dozen technologies which are coming at
us
like artificial intelligence augmented
reality virtual reality
wearables smart speakers internet of
things autonomous cars you know it's
like a breathless
number of technologies which are coming
our way
and we are totally unprepared as a
marketing community and as companies
as to how we are going to navigate that
brave new future so this is number one
number two when you look at some of the
areas like you know if you look at
loyalty as an example we spend
hundreds of billions with a b hundreds
of billions of dollars
every year on loyalty programs now if i
look at
some interesting parallels in people's
real lives
uh a bbc survey which i came across had
said that
uh it was actually the survey was not
done by bbc but it was on bbc.com
they said that more than 70 percent
of the people in a relationship in a
marriage
or living relationship have admitted
to have cheated on their partners
this is in spite of the fact that there
is an explicit or an implicit commitment
with a marriage contract or a legal
contract or religious
mantras whatever it is and they have
consequences
if they are found straight the
consequences could be
financial damage reputational damage
emotional hurt for the people they care
about and so on
in spite of the commitment and the
consequences people
anyway straight they're not lying
now i'm saying as marketers always
stupid
in assuming that people will be loyal to
our brands when they are not loyal in
their own personal lives
i love that right and look at the second
aspect of it which is
and i mean real quick i'm sorry i'm
sorry to interrupt you the sheer
delta in one's appreciation to their
spouse or partner
versus to a coffee or a credit card or a
sneaker
is laughable exactly you said it right
in fact i just tried to hire a put a
hierarchy for people in terms of what is
important in people's lives
because what is their level of absence
of it
and commercial transactions are way way
below there is no concept of loyalty
there
so how do you really think about it so
this is one part of it look at the other
way out
when i grew up in india like in most of
the british commonwealth countries
there are i know those posters which
used to be kept behind the cashier in a
shop
it says the customer is our king or
queen
the question is if customer is truly the
king or
queen is the king loyal to his or her
subjects
or the lot the subjects should be loyal
to the king
or the queen so which means are brands
going to be loyal or should be lying to
their clients or customers
or our customers expected to be like so
we got the equation wrong because as
brands
while we say that customer we are in the
service of the customer
we expect customers to be loyal to us
that's a complete we got it wrong in
terms of the entire perspective
well i mean i'm sorry to interrupt the
the shock that would be the word i would
use the shock
that i was met with in my own body 13
years ago 12 years ago when i entered
the major industry field
fortune 5000 land with my company
vaynermedia
was on a good day
companies considered the customer
on a normal day they spent 100
of their energy on their p l and the cfo
actually ran the company i've never seen
anything like it i
come from ceo land and i am probably
more chief heart officer call it hr
customer service rep i i literally
lived my whole life customer the way i
built both my companies my families of
mine
was employee customer me
my dad immigrant businesses you know
the business is the third child so you
feed it
and not you don't take money out of it
and buy a boat you know and so
the least consumer-centric thing i've
ever seen in my life
is fortune 500 companies
period see at the irony gallery is
you call it customer service which means
you're in the service of the customer
so who should be loyal to whom think
about that
i laugh when people are like our
customers are not brand loyal to us i'm
like they're not your customers
see this is an interesting point raja
right
right the audacity the what is the
slavery
the audacity that because they've tried
your service or have used it for four
years or by your product
you know it's just audacity
and and and and for granted
that people take you know listen coming
from your industry when you have
let's talk or we can talk coalesce
because i'll use cola even though
i think your industry and credit card
had a similar dynamic because you have
two or three or four leaders
but let's use cola but the reason i like
the credit card industry is
in the face of cryptocurrency in the
face of new dynamics
things change and people and people lose
because they take it for granted
and when they're taking it for granted
inevitably there's
underlining resentment unconscious
resentment
at the scale at the consumer and they
are prepared to act on it
when given the alternative so
totally right so so totally right in
fact you know
that's the whole thing the mindset with
which we have to approach
has dramatically changed right now
loyalty is
for example i'm saying we have to
reinvent loyalty
we should actually talk about preference
management
right and preference management at every
stage or every time the consumer has to
make a decision
how do the how does the brand show up
and influence the choice in favor of
itself
that that's what the whole mandate would
be going forward as opposed to saying
i've been the consumer
the consumer is loyal to me etc that has
to evolve
likewise i'm saying advertising right
now as a consumer as an ordinary human
being
do i like advertisements maybe for a
short time during super bowl just to see
what's out there because that's a
cultural moment
but otherwise advertisements are an
absolute nuisance
they're an interruption to my experience
now we talk of consumer experience
design
seamlessness frictionlessness and here
we are when i'm watching a youtube video
for example on some animals or whatever
it could be
every three minutes annoyingly there is
an interruption
now i'm reacting as a consumer as a
normal human being i hate that
at that time i'm just waiting when can
when will that skip
button will come up so i can click on it
i'm not engaged with that ad
and to make my life more difficult they
want me to now suffer through two
advertisements not one there's a one by
two and two by two
like you know this is totally i mean
it's it's by the way
i love this this is exciting me to no
end
they literally when they went to digital
they literally made
the little x on the phone
for you to click out so small that you
would by
accident hit the how do people not
understand
back home raja at the math labs and the
media companies and the analytics teams
everyone's high-fiving look at the
click-through rate
in real life when i miss it and i can't
click it i literally look and i'm like i
will never buy a toyota in my life
i will never like i get mad there you go
like intent matters
and it is very clear when we create that
level of friction for the consumer
to trick them into it's like kidnapping
my attention
exactly without your permission or
without you feeling good about it right
look at this way uh gary on the one hand
we are interrupting them so badly
consumers are therefore reacting right
mo there are estimates anywhere between
600 million
and 2.2 billion people have installed ad
blockers
predominantly in asia it's growing like
there is no tomorrow 600 million it's at
scale
you're talking about 10 plus of your
population in the world or almost 10
percent
one number two they are going to add
free environment and paying money
for example youtube itself gives you an
option to have ad free by paying 12
or 13 every month correct so people
are running look what's happening look
look what's happening with the biggest
medium
in modern history around advertising the
television
the television commercial as you and i
sit and have this discussion right now
is fundamentally over and what i mean by
that
the growth of ott
in the last five years is staggering
netflix is the dominant player zero
commercials
the pro to your point to your point
something that people did not think was
gonna happen
the premium version of the ad-supported
companies the hulus of the world growing
growing because people value time and
they say to themselves
wait a minute let me get this right even
at income levels
that may not seem obvious let me get
this right i can pay
20 a month and not lose these two
minutes
every time i watch something or i can
and they are choosing
even with restrictive average incomes
that you would similar to uber i passed
on uber
famously to my community twice in the
angel round but i
invested in it a little bit later
because i couldn't believe
who was using an uber i was like these
people can't afford this
wait a minute convenience is always
going to be king
and in new york waiting for a yellow cab
for two minutes
is still worse than still being in the
coffee shop hitting the uber
and even though i'm paying 21 and i
can't afford it i'm choosing
convenience and lack of friction and
time so i can afford it actually and
that's what we're going to see in
advertising
people are going to pay for the premium
stuff and ads are going to
go slowly but surely into a place where
they're going to struggle to be consumed
and then what you see in super bowl
where they're very expensive is it's a
it's a hobby to watch it
the companies step up their game from an
entertainment level hence the
celebrities and the creativity
and i think that super bowl like dna is
going to trickle into every single piece
of content they put out in the world
not at the same expense but the effort
and the lack of audacity
and the effort to try to bring value
absolutely and in fact that's exactly
what i say in my book which is
advertising as we know is dead
we have to completely reframe everything
advertising
and how do we go about it right and so
each one of these
uh in a kind of areas i'm uh asking in a
very provocative way
and i'm not just stopping it asking but
i'm also trying to give
some suggested solutions or approaches
which are obviously not comprehensive
people have to keep thinking about
different different
ways of solving the issue and
accomplishing their objectives
but this is what broadly i'm approaching
as far as the book is concerned i feel
so excited uh that finally it has been
printed and it's out in the market
uh on the 9th of february
i love it what um let's bounce around
here a little bit a little bit more
about you how somebody who's listening
how did how did your career in marketing
start
you know what kind of kid were you were
you more art were you more math
little you know little inspiration and
maybe
pattern recognition for or or blueprint
for some of the audience
how did you how did you get to this
point in your career or
or to even bring more value you know
what are the common themes that you've
seen from others and your contemporaries
that have gotten them to the place of
cmoship
which i think a lot of people who are
listening right now actually aspire to
me
so i would say in my own case uh gary i
started
studying chemical engineering and so i
am a data
and a quantitative guide to start with
at the core that's been my training
when i went to mba i wanted to
specialize in environmental management
about you know
pollution control and how to keep the
world green and so on
so i had that sense of purpose and
therefore i was pursuing in that
direction
but something happened during the
internship when i was doing my summer
internship
i overtake overheard a conversation the
company was working
about some advertisement they were
creating to make cosmetics color
cosmetics
more acceptable to people uh
particularly for the conservative
backgrounds in south india
so i said why are these guys missing the
point it should be so simple and they
just
created an ad in five minutes and i said
is it bad to look good was the headline
and they just put the sketch and they
said hey what do you guys think about it
and they were zapped so this is
absolutely
awesome and this is brilliant and
actually they created the campaign
off that now it went on to become a hit
so suddenly when you get that kind of
early success yeah when you get that
information my
affirmation you know skill is so i i
quickly started taking marketing classes
in the second year in specialization and
i started thoroughly enjoying it
so since then i'm sorry i'm trying to
interrupt you i want everybody to hear
this because i'm always thinking about
the audience
back to the whole point of this
conversation
putting yourself in positions for
serendipity
is an incredibly underestimated aspect
of life
and when i hear that story i think about
the other places that he applied that
raja applied for internships
i think about why he even got that
internship
you know i think about all why he was
even in that hall but
being aware this is where i'm going a
little bit different to make it
really important being open to
opportunity
at all times is an incredible skill set
and something i believe in raja
absolutely and i couldn't have
articulated it any better at all
it's so true and because you know all
along for seven years i was pursuing the
uh direction of environmental management
and i just flexed into this
uh pivoted to marketing also
interestingly what it did was
uh i changed quite a few companies you
know
it was going by the standards in my day
i worked at a company where i started a
marketing department
uh and learned the hard way i was the
junior flunkey the three people
marketing department
uh again we produced award-winning ads
and logistics solutions new kind of
pricing models
new kind of packaging i had real fun and
when i was awarded at that time the
marketer of the year
unilever picked me up and i moved to
unilever where i had to
unlearn some of the things that i have
wrongly assumed and learn things in a
more classical grounded kind of a
fashion
and understand structured processes
without losing the entrepreneurial
spirit of my previous
well let's let's go to this because i
know a lot of marketers are going to be
listening
do you feel like a lot of marketers need
to now unlearn the things that the
unilevers and proctors and others had
taught
i think so yeah absolutely i do too
because these frameworks yeah go ahead
when the frameworks you have been taught
or you have learned on
themselves are collapsing then you have
to absolutely relearn and you have to
unlearn some other stuff that you have
actually
picked up along the way so that's one
thing the other thing i would say
is i have always been very open to a
move
so in fact one of my biggest shocks and
this is a big lesson for me in my life
is
when i joined unilever at the time the
head of
marketing said that you have to start
your career in sales not in marketing
the i said why should i be in sales
because i thought sales was for the less
intelligent less creative people
only gifted with the gift of gab so he
said no you need to understand
what it means to sell believe me i hated
the first few weeks of doing sales
but then slowly i started appreciating
it and over a period of time i realized
marketing in isolation is fluffy correct
you need to be able to connect the dots
to either sales or
business outcomes what's the purpose of
marketing i'll be honest with you this
is my biggest problem in this ecosystem
i'm a marketer and a brand man
but the sheer lack of connection to
reality
in the creative marketing industry is
ludicrous
and tone-deaf and and actually grossly
negligent
by most brand people and creative
agencies period
withholding out i totally agree and i
think that's one of the reasons why
i keep saying that marketing isn't an
existential crisis precisely for that
reason
because we have as marketers isolated
ourselves in these
bubbles doing marketing for marketing
sake and then
not really mainstreaming ourselves and
companies so much so that there are
studies now which are showing that a
bulk of ceos don't
have faith and trust in their marketing
departments as business drivers
they're eliminating the roles of cmos
they are fragmenting marketing
distributing marketing
responsibilities outside of marketing
and so on roger
raja roger are you
anticipating discomfort
from your peers when they read this
because it sounds like you're going to
be poking
at the golden goose the kind like the
establishment of that did you
have you given it to some friends in the
industry
i mean you know this sounds like
listen i'm getting excited by the second
i wasn't you know you know me i don't
i go in pretty improv so i didn't have a
full sense of
i i had a good sense of you and you were
thoughtful so i said yes to
do the podcast i don't think i really
understood
from it sounds like a different angle
and clearly a very different demeanor
and tone and energy but it seems like
you're going to be poking at something
that has caused a lot of people to be
anxious about my communication
not style of what i actually say are you
anticipating that and have you had
people read it
yet or to look at it yeah
right and i wanted to make sure firstly
because i'm doing it
i had to cover all my uh what you call
logic
my data support and my examples and
everything had to be
perfectly prepared correct correct which
i spent some time to really do that well
second i ran this manuscript past some
of my peers
like you know the same of unileve museum
of microsoft of ibm was general mills
and etc
and i was so delighted whether it is a
classical company of those sorts which i
just listed out
or the contemporary ones like the
facebook and twitter their cmos etc i
have gone through that i went to
professors at howard and yale
asked them to review and i went to
matter subject matter experts and
companies
areas like blockchains and ai and so on
and finally i went to a few ceos
including mastercard's own ceo
i feel very grateful that they were
absolutely applauding uh the content
and then the siraja i think somebody had
to call it and you're doing it
so i said will be able to endorse the
book then
because one is you know we can have a
secret private conversation
where you pack you know the backend of
his great stuff
so they agreed and they have actually
given their endorsements
and this is the who is who of the
marketing community from the
practitioners point of view
and also from ceos where they are
actually leveraging
you know marketing in their companies
and all kinds of companies i feel
extremely grateful for the response i
got
and if i can say just one quote which
stood out for me more than anyone else
this is from the cmo of general mills
ivan pollard
his quote goes something like this he
says this book
will do to our view of marketing what
copernicus's book did
to our view of the world it will change
it forever
now i felt the probably the highest
compliment that i could aspire for from
a peer of mine
and i felt incredibly grateful and so
far the response has been very good
a lot of people are uncomfortable saying
that wow you know do i want to
love my ceo to see this uh you know how
do i act
so there is obviously tension uh but i
think it is necessary and it's a healthy
tension as best as i see it
i couldn't agree more like uh everybody
uh i i
i'm sure you can pick this up on amazon
and barnes nobles and all the other
things raja one more time the name of
the book
because i encourage everybody look
everybody who listens to this knows
i don't learn from reading so i don't
tend to read
but the people that i allow on this
podcast to talk about
books or people i have a read on them
which makes me
uncomfortably comfortable to give them
this platform i'd love everybody in the
vayner nation to pick up this book if
it's hit accord
or maybe maybe in a lot of ways
creates an intellect or a black and
white or a mathematical or a different
angle to a lot of the things i believe
in so
raja as i leave now please tell them the
name of the book and thank you for being
on the show
thank you very much the name of the book
again is quantum marketing
uh and uh you know please do pick it up
and again
i would love to engage with any one of
you if you have uh
ideas that challenge what i'm saying i
would love to uh you know have this
conversations
i'm on twitter or on linkedin raja
rajamana
and love to do that and gary thank you
so much and
you know that i look up to you as one of
those mavericks and
absolutely brilliant folks who disrupted
the industry in a way
that nobody could have anticipated and i
think the first time that we met i
i mentioned this to you saying that wow
you know and
you know i i continue that feeling and
i'm so delighted
for your support and uh look forward to
having more conversations in the future
cheers my friends thank you very much
thank you
youtube what's up it's garyvee first of
all thank you so much i hope you're
doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon